we have with us jj ali marandi who
defeated el sharma yadavadi
jj first of all a topsy-turvy event for
you you started off quite slowly while
you won one of your first games but
after that you lost three games in a row
and then you finished on a blazing hot
plus two out of your last three games
first of all how do you assess your
event
yeah a lot of ups and downs but uh i
mean i can't complain at the end since i
finished it with a win
and fifty percent it's not so bad
considering i was at -2 at some point so
i come back in the last three rounds i
think it's
yeah not bad uh very very uh concrete
game today let's take a look at that and
take us through the critical moments of
that being
um well critical moments i think was as
early as when he played knight before
also what was inspiration
uh the inspiration is yeah
i just decided to play something sharp
and yeah that's well very it's the
famous duboff kayaking game where he
sucked queen jesus that was just the
inspiration i think
um so yeah i did check this line but for
some reason i wasn't remembering much
and i played b4 b5 i think it's correct
but knight before didn't even cross my
mind to check what i did check i think
was d3 but that's about it so i don't
know
how it goes but after night before i was
completely shocked
i think i did
play fg and cb which should be correct
and after rook g7 i spent all my time
calculating a4 which i think is
actually winning but i ended up playing
queen e5 and blundered f6
um
and i have no explanation on why i
blended f6 it was just
blindness
i was focusing on rook takes g2 for
a very long time and i'm not even saying
it's bad move but after spending all my
time on a4 i don't know why i didn't
play it it's
it's inexplicable but after f6 i'm
pretty sure i'm lost yes correct
at least your evaluation is still on
point no like after he played f6 i was
like okay do i resign or do i play a few
more moves uh but i played queen h5 and
i think it's okay yeah you are a peace
out i'm a piece of that was my own
play yeah yeah bishop f7 and queen h3 so
i mean i was thinking maybe he'll go
bishop e6 and make it draw but the
position is so bad that i don't yeah it
doesn't make sense for him to do it but
uh in the game i think he blended like
bishop f4 later on so that's why he
played queen d5 i'm sure that he saw
castle's bishop e6
queen h6 king f7 but he said he missed
bishop f4 and it's very important
because if queen f3 i have queen g7
so and after that i thought like
i'm back in the game i'm not sure if i'm
actually back in the game you are but i
thought i'm back in the game and
yeah he probably has to make a draw with
rook g6 i think that was his like like
practically speaking yeah and after it
takes rick g7 just do that and like
leave because if you put if you let me
put the bishop on g3
which happened in the game i
consolidated somehow and
i don't know if he can uh you have a
piece yeah at this point you can even
sacrifice a piece with 92 at some point
right
yeah like i was even thinking if i can
go like knight c3 rook d1 at some point
like just give it up and like get the
rook into the game
rookie one yeah i mean i don't know
where his crucial mistake was i'm not
sure about the objective evaluation but
here i felt very comfortable like i can
finally like get my pieces out
and
rook g6 is
okay interesting seems to be the final
mistake no not quite the final the
engine wants you to take on c3 i don't
know why
i saw that but i i just take back with
the queen yes oh
that's just yeah extra pawn and a very
weak king on g8 for black it's i mean
it's i cannot explain why i didn't even
see knight i think i wasn't just looking
at that direction
like i was really focused on rookie
seven
oh yeah i tried to go for the checkmate
that's my student all right rook effect
seems to be plus one but he took on b4
yeah here i mean i knew this cannot work
but
yeah yeah this looks like oh
yeah yeah it looks like yeah this is
checkmate right yeah final knight c3 was
nice otherwise it's not working let's
just show that real quick because that
is funny uh if you
if you don't have knight c3 not so easy
huh
yeah i wasn't sure how exactly i was
focusing on knight c3 dc3 rook d1 but
then i saw queen c4 queen f7 yeah much
easier nice triangulation
well that was a nice
a very moved game like a lot of things
happened
in a short amount of time very short
amount of time you got 29 moves we have
a complete poem and a drama
yeah i mean i can't complain since i won
but
a very important final touch to your
event congratulations jj and we're
looking forward to see you in the next
events here hopefully hopefully
well thank you jj and if you like the
play of these collegiate players and